bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
maintenant un mot pour commencer de la
situation dont votre hôpital m'écouter
les deux services de réanimation
médicale et chirurgicale son plein donc
nous avons environ 55% délais qui sont
occupées par les patients kobe en fait
nous avons des programmes et 30 % des
interventions chirurgicales en début de
semaine ce qui a donné un certain volant
de lits pour pouvoir admettre davantage
de patients s'ils venaient à l'hôpital
pour des colites 19 donc aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 55% nous dit occupée par
les patients ayant d'un communisme et
vous craignez à la saturation des lits
en réanimation caisse créée fait pour
empêcher cette situation
alors on va dire nos lits son statut
mais c'est pas dire que y'a aucun lit
vide donc ils sont occupés soit par des
patients on l'a qu'ovide soit par
d'autres patients qui sont tous dans des
situations graves
évidemment si le nombre de patients
venaient à augmenter et que ce soit lié
à la coved 19 ou peut-être au
refroidissement des températures avec
des compensations pathologie devrions
ouvrir de nouveaux lits en dehors des
secteurs habituel de la réalisation
c'est à dire sortir hors des murs est
pour le moment la situation plutôt
parfaitement ce contrôle on a
l'impression que peut-être il ya un
début d'effet en tout cas sur les
contaminations des décisions de
confinement prise au ministre le
ministère de la santé a annoncé une
multiplication par deux du nombre donné
en réanimation manifestement vous n'en
n'avez pas encore vu la couleur
alors non multiplication par deux du
nombre de vidéos animations je crois que
c'est impossible car évidemment qui dit
ouvrir un nouveau lydie y affecter le
personnel paramédical et médicales
nécessaires
or en fait pour pouvoir avoir le nombre
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants voir
de médecin pour s'occuper des patients
il faut en fait des programmes et
d'autres activités notamment les
interventions chirurgicales car le
personnel qui travaille au bloc
opératoire à les poupées
dans ce nécessaire pour travailler en
réanimation donc si on ouvre davantage
de l'iru va devoir réduire l'offre de
soins d'un autre côté et c'est justement
là que peut-être est en train d'être
créé un autre problème comment est ce
qu'on fait pour s'occuper des autres
malades non qu'ovide c'est tout là toute
la difficulté effectivement c'est de
trouver le bon équilibre c'est à dire
effectivement à tout instant et bien
avoir une certaine anticipation et bien
sûr ceci est possible grâce au plan
blanc grâce à la possibilité de
collaboration avec les autres hôpitaux y
compris les cliniques privées et grâce
aussi bien sûr aux autorités sanitaires
régionales la rs il ya tout instant une
vision globale de l'offre de soins et
permet évidemment de donner un certain
nombre de recommandations directeur de
crise des hôpitaux pour adapter les
offres de chaque hôpital à les cliniques
privées qui peuvent prendre en charge 30
% 1 des patients covin c'est un soutien
indispensable aujourd'hui
oui ça a été un soutien indispensable au
cours du premier pic épidémique
à part en ile de france si nous n'avions
pas nue l'aide du secteur privé lors du
2 mars avril nous aurions dû
sélectionner les patients par le
capacités donc effectivement grâce à eux
ceci n'a pas été possible et aujourd'hui
jouent un rôle également important bien
sûr pour que les cliniques privées
puissent prendre en charge les patients
victimes de lakovic 19 ils doivent des
programmes et parfois des propos mais
massivement un certain nombre
d'interventions non urgentes donc on
espère rapidement évidemment ses besoins
de lit les patients kovy devons
atteindre un plateau et commencer à
diminuer merci beaucoup
renault megane d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
je rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris